[Music]
in the depths of their underwater
Kingdom the mighty dragon Lords quaked
with fear before them prance Sun Wukong
The Monkey King
the legendary troublemaker had been
hatched from a stone schooled in divine
magic and was currently brandishing the
Dragonlords most treasured weapon this
magical staff originally large enough to
measure the depth of a great flood now
obeyed the monkey Kings will and shrank
at his touch terrified of this bill will
during power the Dragons graciously
allowed Sun Wukong to cap the staff The
Monkey King stowed the weapon away and
gleefully sped back to his kingdom to
show this treasure to his tribe of
warrior monkeys after a lavish
celebration Sun Wukong fell into a deep
sleep but just as he began to dream The
Monkey King quickly realized two things
the first was that this was no ordinary
slumber the second was that he wasn't
alone suddenly he found himself caught
in the clutches of two grizzly figures
at first The Monkey King didn't know who
his captors were but as they dragged him
towards their city's gates Sun Wukong
realized his deathly predicament
these were soul collectors tasked with
transporting mortals to the realm of the
Dead this was the domain of the death
Lords who mercilessly sorted souls and
designed gruesome punishments
[Music]
from here the kingdom of death was laid
out before him he could see the death
humans palaces and the fabled bridge
across the river and I her Manning the
bridge was an old woman who offered
worthy souls a bowl of soup after
drinking the spirits forgot their
previous life and was sent back to the
world of the living in a new form
further below were the souls not worthy
of reincarnation in this twisting maze
of chambers unfortunate spirits endured
endless rooms of punishment from
mountain spiked with sharp blades two
pools of blood and vats of boiling oil
but soon Wukong was not about to accept
torture or reincarnation as the soul
collectors attempted to drag him through
the gates The Monkey King whipped out
his staff and swung himself out of their
clutches his battle cries and the clang
of weapons echoed throughout the
underworld sensing a disturbance the ten
death lords swooped upon him but they
had never met such resistance from a
mortal soul what was this unusual
creature and was he immortal a god or
something else the Lord consulted the
book of death and life a tome which
showed the time of every living Souls
death not knowing what category this
strange being was under the death Road
struggled to find Sun Wukong at first
but The Monkey King knew just where to
look unfortunately the records confirmed
the death Lords claim soon Wukong was
scheduled to die this very night but The
Monkey King was not afraid this was far
from the first time he defied destiny in
his quest for wisdom and power his past
rebellions have earned him the power to
transfigure his body ride clouds at
dizzying speeds and govern his tribe
with magic and martial arts in this
crisis he saw yet another opportunity
with a flash of his nimble fingers The
Monkey King struck his own name from the
book before the death Lord could respond
he found the names of his monkey tribe
and swept them away as well
liberated from the bonds of death Sun
Wukong began to battle his way out of
the underworld he deftly defeated
endless swarms of angry spirits before
tripping on his way out of the kingdom
just before he hit the ground
Sun Wukong suddenly awoke in his bed at
first he thought the journey might have
been a dream but the Monkey King felt
his new immortality surging from the top
of his head to the tip of his tail with
a cry of triumph he woke his warriors to
share his latest adventure and commenced
another round of celebration
for more tales of death-defying
adventures in the underworld check out
these two myths choose carefully though
one of them does not end happily
[Music]